in this video we will showcase to you
the complete timeline of
two barrels and important events that
happened within Toho's Godzilla master
universe we decided not to include
Gamera and other kaiju that hath no
connection with the main Godzilla
timeline but others like Rodin and
Mothra are well covered in ass Timon we
start off with prehistoric times that
include what hey say and show events as
it would be too confusing to do them in
branching timelines going in and out
from the future to the past and back
again
the Millennium series of events are all
standalone except for their connection
to the original 1954 Evander Godzilla
first appear so 550 million years ago a
colony of microscopic crustaceans from
the Precambrian era tries by living in
anaerobic environments these organisms
are later known as destoroyah
300 million years ago mega Neera
dragonflies evolved on earth in the
Carboniferous period way before
dinosaurs
in the early cretaceous age Tarasov
creatures mutated and evolved into
Rona's well as the mega Newlands from
the lesser-known mega Noura in the
Cretaceous age rainbow Matra babbles the
young cretaceous king ghidorah and kills
it leaving only one of its tail intact
millions of years ago Godzilla had
frequent fights with Angoras both of
them were territorial millions of years
ago again destoroyah destroys all life
and planet Mars and comes to earth but
was met with resistance and battle
against Mothra 10,000 BC Batra was
created by us to stop an ancient
civilization from changing the climate
later it battled with Mothra and was
trapped in the northern ocean thousands
of years ago kingdom of sea Tobia is
established hundreds of years ago
Matra relocates to infant Island and
forms a bond with the show vision
fairies in February 1944 while treadin
by the American soldiers the Japanese
soldiers were saved by a mysterious
dinosaur in 1954 Godzilla was first
awakened and emerges to destroy the city
of Tokyo he was eventually killed by the
oxygen destroyer weapon in the same year
the future ensue came from 1992 left 3
door ads exposing them to radiation from
the nuclear tests to later evolved into
King Ghidorah the Showa era of events
followed directly after Godzilla was
killed by the oxygen destroyer weapon so
in 1955 another Godzilla is awakened and
fights with Anguirus and burns him to
death with his atomic breath later
Godzilla is trapped under an avalanche
by the humans in arrest in 1956 -
rodents were awakened from beneath the
mountain and battles to meganula on
swamp they both died together under an
erupting volcano in 1961 the discovery
of show vision natives and Mothra in
infant Island they were kidnapped but
later rescued by Mothra in 1962 two
iconic monsters go head-to-head
King Kong vs. Godzilla the g-man had the
upper hand until calm was revitalized by
a lightning strike and fall again to a
draw falling over a cliff to the ocean
while Kong swam back to shore God
swam away in 1964 the Japanese went to
ask for help from the Shogun against
Godzilla terrorizing their country but
their plea wasn't accepted by the Shogun
fairies until Mothra herself decides to
fight Godzilla although she dies two of
her offsprings survivor and stop
Godzilla in the same year
tree kaiju unite to fight against the
space monster called Ghidorah this evil
was ultimately defeated and sent back to
space by Rodin the new Matra and
Godzilla fighting together in 1965 the
zillions plead with humanity to borrow
Godzilla and Rodan to defeat King
Ghidorah only to betray the humans and
unleash the monsters on earth but in the
end Ghidorah and the aliens were
defeated by Rodin and Godzilla in 1966
Godzilla is awaken and Letty Island and
fights Amira and destroys a Red Bamboo
terrorist base
he later challenges Mothra on the same
island but then both escaped just in
time to avoid being blown off along with
the island by a nuclear bomb in 1967
Godzilla says Manila from to Kamakura
and later both of them killed the
commander in a combined atomic breath
attack in 1971 a pollution kaiju called
Hedorah arises and Godzilla bals it but
couldn't win he later teamed up with the
military and uses their weapon to defeat
it in 1972 the Nebula M a lien Slayer K
Dora and Jagan from space to destroy
human civilization but the signal was
caught on by Godzilla who along with
Anguirus defeats the two space monsters
and sent them back in 1973 angered by
the destruction of monster island the
seat opions
sent their God Megalon to destroy
humanity nebula a million Suns Jagan to
eight Megalon but then they would be
filled by Godzilla and Jet Jaguar in
1974 Mechagodzilla emerges from a
mountain and nearly kills an Kira's it
defeats Godzilla as well it fights King
Cesar to a standstill until Godzilla
returns and destroys it in 1975 a mad
scientist rebuilds Mechagodzilla and
mentally controls a kaiju called
Titanosaurus sending them both to Tokyo
these two bosses were later the field by
Godzilla
Japanese military combining forces 24
years later in 1999 the Gallic aliens
managed to control the minds of all the
Earth's monsters and send him to destroy
all Zilla that's capital cities but UNSC
manages to retrieve the device and free
the monsters the calyx and King Ghidorah
to battle all the mosses but was
defeated he sent another monster called
fire dragon but was later revealed to be
a flying saucer and it too was destroyed
by Godzilla
now comes the Heisei era which ignores
all the events that happen from 1955 to
destroy all monsters rebooting the
franchise by making a sequel to the
first Godzilla attack in 1954 and what
happens to the years after it so in 1984
a new Godzilla arises after 30 years and
this one engages in a battle with an
armored fortress weapon called super Rex
Godzilla was then trapped inside a
volcano 1989 five years later Godzilla's
genes are mixed with plants and from it
arises a new kaiju called biollante
Godzilla escaped from the volcano and
battles and defeats this plan kaiju 1992
the future ins from the Year tu-204
travel to 1992 and use Ghidorah to
subjugate Japan but wasn't he nd filled
by Godzilla all the future mecha King
Ghidorah manages to take Godzilla away
into the ocean mid 1992 the United
Nations established the UN GCC or United
Nations Godzilla countermeasure center
in the same time Garuda and
Mechagodzilla are being created 1994
baby Godzilla is born and in the same
time Godzilla and Rodan bounce with
Garuda and make a Godzilla roar and dies
and his life force regenerates Godzilla
powering up the g-man to a level that he
destroys super mecha godzilla
in the same year godzilla sells in space
brought by Mothra grows into space
Godzilla near a black hole space
Godzilla makes it to earth and bouts
with Godzilla and Mogu era 1996
Godzilla's heart which acts as a nuclear
reactor is nearing a nuclear meltdown
which threatens the entire earth
meanwhile a colony of mutated creatures
known as destoroyah emerge from the
ocean changing form and terrorizing
Japan both Godzilla and destoroyah die
in the end 1996
Mothra and Matra Leo fights desgidora
saving the world from imminent
destruction in 1997 water fights Negara
a monster created by an ancient advanced
civilization designed to manage
pollution 1998 matra and Mothra Leo
fights Ghidorah travels back in time to
mature into an armored form and then
defeats to Edoras one in the past
and the other in the present-day tu-204
mecha Ginga dork sent back in time to
1992 to help save Japan from Godzilla's
rage from here on n the Millennium
series of events are all standalone
events that completely ignores the
Heisei and Showa periods and events but
keeps on rebooting the sequel to the
1954 events in 1998 a monster which was
similar to Godzilla attacks New York
City this was called Zilla in 1999 45
years after the events of the original
Godzilla film he fights a new monster
called Agra in 2000 yet another reboot
and this time Godzilla fights another
monster called megaguirus which is a
queen of the mutated creatures from the
cretaceous period in 2001 following his
death in 1954 spirits of people killed
in world war ii by the japanese
reanimate godzilla to attack japan but
his monster was stopped by three
legendary beasts The Guardian monsters
Barragan Mothra and Ghidorah 2000 2002
and 2003 godzilla vs. Mechagodzilla and
Godzilla Tokyo SOS are the only two
events and millennium series that are
related to each other
2004 final wars in the 21st century
extensive warfare nuclear testing and
careless science had mutated or awakened
the great beasts of all shapes and sizes
Godzilla bells monsta x in the end which
later evolved into kaiser Ghidorah the
strongest form of Ghidorah the Ray were
series of events
knows everything and is a complete
reboot of the Godzilla series in 2016 a
mysterious creature appears off the
coast and then comes inland and evolves
four times into four fourths of Godzilla
ending in a fourth form that is a
gigantic and super powerful but from it
emanates humanoid forms of Godzilla
which are human size from here on n is
the timeline of the animated series in
1999 creatures and mosses arise but all
of them including humanity are driven to
near extinction by Godzilla tuna 2000ad
the survivors returned to earth and
experienced a time dilation sending them
20,000 years into the future and they
defeat a smaller form of Godzilla but
only to Rhea wake the biggest Godzilla
version ever seen Godzilla earth and in
the same year the reawakening a Godzilla
City which nearly turns the entire
planet into itself but was in the end
destroyed by Godzilla the planet eater
Ghidorah was then someone to kill
Godzilla and consume the planet this
interdimensional creature was
invulnerable to physical damage until it
was later merged with Earth's physics
and becomes materialized therefore
allowing Godzilla to defeat it and send
it back so this brings us to the end of
a long timeline of Toho Godzilla
cinematic universe
do you like share and subscribe for more
related content